I like seeing powerful independent
chicks that like pow here's [__]
boundaries [__] yeah yeah like I
wouldn't need to have a further
conversation like there's no more back
and forth that needs to happen at that
point so I like that and I also like
death situations too huh what's your
favorite okay
[Music]
welcome back to another very special
episode of careful boys today we not
only have Anthony Baptist but we got Geo
in the house
[Applause]
when was the last time you were here
dude I was here last week you don't
remember I wasn't here last week I'm
just kidding it's been a minute
she was here a whole different hairstyle
ago oh yeah yeah when Ken was doing the
sexy Vietnamese uh oh dude it's pretty
sexy yeah it was really good it changed
my mind I wasn't there that day but that
was really funny because the video went
up okay okay yeah Joe wasn't here oh man
oh yeah that's right it was it it did
pretty well dude people really resonated
with Ken they agreed with you yeah no I
was just like I I wasn't convinced until
I saw it in the flesh and I'm like oh
[__] can was the most Superior by far
yeah he smoked us oh that's because you
were like Vietnamese sound Goofy and
then can did it and you're like I didn't
know it could sound like that yeah he
represented we're talking about your
sexy Vietnamese voice
no I was saying I like the Asian accent
that Hawk has that's the one I was
that's British she likes Hawks yeah and
he convinced me oh I convinced her no
Kan was sitting in your seat because you
were gone and you left everyone hanging
for like a whole month Anthony maybe
like two months oh yeah because he did
the Asian Squad we weren't here to see
it that's when we're trying to relive it
we're at the yulin festival and you were
in uh
Festival
did all my dogs say what's up and then
they couldn't because they're dying oh
my God
who let the dog out
yeah and then DMX came when he was alive
they booked artists according to the
Snoop Dogg he always performed the hate
dog was a great dog he when he was alive
[__] lit ass dog Festival I think
that would make the yulin Dog Festival
pop off a little more oh no I think it
would help the sarcasm read a little
better yeah and they had like a special
like uh meet and greet with Michael Vick
meet and greet Michael Vick dog con yeah
yeah yeah dude he's got like a plastic
table up and he's just signing
autographs
Pitbulls and Parolees yeah Caesar Milan
yeah like everyone from
those might be competitors yeah I think
they always have that like if you go to
porn con they got [__] like Planned
Parenthood and Jenna Jameson
really yeah yeah you ever been I think
Planned Parenthood is different Cesar
Milan's more like if you're putting like
I don't know picketing like Catholics
outside but they're still there at Anime
conventions you know it's one of the
most shameful things I've ever said back
in the early 2000s I told my friends
that the hottest the place to see the
hottest girls was Planned Parenthood
Whittier
look up the Yelp reviews some of the
best places to find a girl today is in
the lobby of a clinic yeah what kind of
Clinic
a sex clip shortening Clinic
STD clinic Planned Parenthood but then
how do you what do you say about why
you're there no you sit there and then
you're just like
you know just get my box checked you
know okay you want to check it for me
keep it casual keep be mysterious yeah
because one you know that they're
they're they're down to Thug that's why
they're there yeah because you know
they're reactive or maybe they were down
[__] maybe this is like they're there
because they're like it's no longer down
to [__] for a while no but he's on to
something because they're sad and they
need someone to like Will Ferrell at
funerals so happy oh that's probably way
better yeah but in most cases they're
there for Family Planning okay planning
to whether keep or destroy or
it says destroy it's not really there
they're not really there for herpes all
day planned parenthood keeper destroy
your family so what's your opening line
to someone that you run into it you come
here often
that's a good question you gotta you
gotta test the water yeah what if they
say yes what's the follow-up if she's
hot oh me too yeah and I'm like so what
you in for what the [__] is it just like
a prison yeah and then watch it in for
yeah and if she goes oh you know like
just be responsible doing my tests and
getting condoms and you know being a
very responsible sexual adult sexual
active adult and I'll be like cool
you like hamburgers
second chapter that's act two and then
she's all like oh I love hamburgers I'm
like where do you like hamburgers
because like in and out and I'm like me
too and I'm like maybe we can go
hamburger sometime and then there's an
In-N-Out joke that was in there but it's
okay we can skip over oh wow
Planned Parenthood yep I'm not very good
what's your internet joke say it yeah do
it no that's that's the point of the
joke you announced that it was there but
you don't say it that's true is that
Chinese style is that a penetration joke
move forward yes it was thank you Nick
for explaining it to this doofus over
here what were some of the places that
you guys thought were good areas to find
the hottest chicks the hottest ladies or
not necessarily hot but just quality
it's your Bart because I never saw any
of those games being played he's like
the bank
don't do it don't do it because they
have to talk to you bank tellers dude
they're the best I think that was mainly
in my early 20s I think it was more of a
dice roller
you look like you roll the dice every
day really no so it was more just like I
didn't have a place I think it was more
about myself building up my own
confidence
so if I had an urge I just had to go up
and talk to someone see how [__]
boring that [__] is you see that [__]
that's what I that was I was trying to
open up and then it's
interesting I'm on team Geo I was like
come on dude
it's a little irony coming from here but
I like it but you see like why I had to
make all the moves that's cool oh you
did make all the moves yeah
check it out patreon
do you remember the first move you made
on them where you're like I'm gonna get
this Muffler yeah like so we were
texting back and forth a lot that it was
like it went beyond friends where I was
like okay this [__] is not gonna
say [__] I'm like all right I don't like
to hold things I just want to see where
we're going so I was like hey I've been
thinking about you a lot first one check
it out of the friend zone yeah that is
do you think the whole time he was like
man Geo is like really good at
conversations and [__] man like I she's
like one of like the coolest friends she
might even be my new best friend and
then like later you're like you know
what I've been thinking about YouTube
and then he's like man what a cool
person and then later like you have to
really be in his face butt ass naked and
he goes oh it's like that so you know
the whole story sorry you know the whole
what was your reaction to her saying
I've been thinking about you that's
really sweet I was like oh I've been
thinking about you too literally what he
said give me a text that's the exact
same reaction he had like before cameras
rolled and she was like he looks hot
he literally went old
phones were like every number had three
letters yeah so you had to go
yeah it was like that the good old days
so then after that was his opportunity
to be like all right let's settle the
score here let's see where we take this
nothing we never said the word score I
know I'm just trying to I'm just trying
to score yeah yeah it's conceptual oh
you missed that one but I do I do
remember exactly where I was when this
is happening because this was during
Christmas break because I was staying at
Joe's house and then oh yeah why when
you live right here
I was at UCLA now you're asking
he's like what are you [__] idiot 20
years later yeah why did you do this I
was living at Joe's house that's true so
we could bulk like do JK stuff like
shoot send out shirts and all that stuff
and then I remember uh back then you
were still talking on AIM so I couldn't
wait to talk to her and I'm like joking
along just like a log in gonna have to
use his computer because that was the
monitor that I was like this still so I
could log in to go talk to her I'm done
I would log out and then Joe would log
back in on his aim and then he would
keep talking yeah you have to share a
computer damn that's funny
I do remember that but then when you
told me it was after you guys went
snowboarding and then you told me or
something that's the start of it yeah
yeah you guys went snowboarding as
platonic friends super platonic and
there were supposed to be a lot more
people with us and then they all flaked
oh is that when it started yeah so when
you told them was after yeah that's when
we started talking yeah because like we
were always friends and like we didn't
like each other and like I didn't see
him like that he didn't see me like that
and then all the friends bailed on us
and he just showed up at my house
because he was picking everyone up and I
was the one with the truck so I'm gonna
throw snowboards in my car yeah and then
I see
what did you think
[Laughter]
yeah I remember like feeling like man
it's gonna be so awkward I've never
spent alone time with this guy ever and
I'm like [__] I gotta talk to him [__]
today's video is brought to you by Lumi
let me tell you I am quite the hippie
these days I live in Hawaii you know I
like to be in the nature but I sweat a
lot I swear so much that I'm like I need
something that goes beyond my armpits
but at the same time I don't want to do
all this chemically crazy stuff that's
full of metals soaks into my skin I
don't feel sick and I'm gonna it's good
it's like I'm trying to be in nature but
I'm putting all of these toxic things
all over my skin what to do thankfully
Lumi has the solution for all of this
they have aluminum free parablend free
products that you can use for all over
your body such as this cool cucumber
deodorant wipe you could put it all over
it feels so fresh
like cucumbers that's what I like about
it is it's made for the entire body so
some people got stinky places in certain
areas like my ex-girlfriend in high
school I don't know what was wrong with
their ears girl but you can't be using
deodorant on your ears so thank God
you're probably 39 now but they and you
probably lived a very stinky long life
but now you can use this and just
troubleshoot the ears because it's ph
balanced developed by OB GYN and it can
finally cure your ears so maybe you can
finally get married and now you can
smell like Tangerine ears instead of
infection years the Lumi starter pack is
perfect for new customers comes with the
solid Stick deodorant and a cream tube
deodorant and along with two free
products of your choice like the mini
body wash and the deodorant wipes and
free shipping as a special offer for
listeners new customers get five dollars
off the Lumi starter pack with code
OTR at lumide.com that it equates to
over 40 percent off your Lumi starter
pack when you visit Lumi deodorant.com
and use the code OTR so like as all the
friends were like canceling the why did
he still think it was like a go because
then we're gonna show up at my house no
they all confirmed you know how like
when you confirm to show up but then you
end up don't show up that's like that I
don't know about that because usually I
say I don't show up when I don't show up
but anyways they're Vietnamese like you
and they just didn't show up I'm Chinese
when it's convenient
her house was the meeting place got it
and they sat there and said where yeah
we kept texting and like people were
like after like three hours later that I
woke up sorry I overslept yeah yeah [__]
like that but they were already in the
mountains saying they [__] bailed on
us yeah it was like that good thing they
did yeah good thing I wasn't invited
because I would have gone you weren't
invited probably not you were part of a
different like Circle at that time like
you were still in it but not with those
guys I had a lot of friends you love
snowboarding too I know but they
wouldn't invite me sometimes they do
their own things
so that was the joining of the circles
at the time let's talk about that more
like you not being invited how did that
make you
something happened
it literally Joe we were all friends but
then I was always treated like the extra
friend that they weren't really friends
with but they call me a homie and I was
like if I'm a homie then how come when
you guys have all these events you don't
always invite me it's only selectively
[__] tell them but I also remember back
in the day I had a lot of [__]
friends and I was always there you had a
[__] I know so they probably were like
oh they already knew my plans so they
didn't bother but like I just don't like
that they didn't invite me just ask
right just [__] ask did you feel hurt
by them
yeah yeah I did Joe had was in a bunch
of circles
for you to will you guys take the
snowboarding now yeah can we all go
somewhere we go snowboarding now just
the three of you maybe me and him yeah
she doesn't like snowboarding so it's
just me and him usually she doesn't even
like story but she yeah
let me just test the world so when you
guys went just the two of you were there
any moments where you no no breakthrough
moments he just took off down the hill
and you were just we didn't even make it
that's the thing on the way up to Big
Bear we didn't make it yeah they started
making out so hard we made it uh we made
it at the end and then your truck got
stuck or some [__] or was one second
time convenient yeah so what happened
was we were going on our way to Big Bear
and then a snowstorm came and then it
and then so all the cars you know it's
like a two-way street like one way up
one way down so everyone have to turn
their ignition off because that's how
stuck you were so we were stuck in my
car for four hours isn't that Danger
where'd you guys pee I didn't need to
pee inside the truck I think maybe at
that point I was feeling butterflies and
I didn't even know it oh
yeah I get nervous I want to pee more
than you maybe I wasn't nervous then
maybe there were no butterflies until
after huh maybe so that you guys when
waited for the snowstorm you just did a
u-turn you said I think we just went
back home the first time I know we we we
went nightboarding a little bit yeah it
was night boarding week snowboarded and
then we took off
when did you consciously decide that you
were interested in him like that I think
my mind was really so like I think we're
all this way where once you're a homie
like you're in that Circle so there's no
sexual feeling attraction nothing at all
okay we locked eyes
and I'm looking at Ryan and look at all
you guys Nick's like the JK doorknob
everyone got a turn already oh [__]
maybe you should keep that down low hey
bro
that one's really good I'm not that easy
so like yeah um I think we in my brain
we were still friends and I'm like oh
this this friend is like really friend
now like cool like I don't want to talk
to my other friends as much as I want to
talk to this friend oh that's cool so I
think my brain just kept fighting the
fact that I like was feeling something
for him so there's a way out of the
friend zone yeah for wrong yeah well for
I guess each way right because he didn't
like me like that either from like a
semi superficial level is he like your
type
uh he's very much my type superficial
level
he's surprised look how surprised he is
yeah I can't tell if you like that or
not yeah I always thought you told me I
was ugly
what you said that uh [__] around oh
okay
um well that's what I've been memorizing
the last 10 years because I like like it
literal you think Bart's handsome I do I
really do think he sounds
um I like very athletic build bodies
they show them yes I like very athletic
I like very like stand up back straight
type of dudes
yes don't slouch bar yeah be sexy for
her she is doing that ever
but yeah he's my type for sure
that's romantic other than the fact that
if this doesn't make the first move
but that was his game you
[__] hit on me but it's like that's a
good tragedy you ended up chasing him I
did I I hunted him down climbed that
mountain I did even I thought you guys
were friends when when I remember you
like didn't make it public that you guys
were together yeah and I was like what a
cool friendship
because I really didn't know
I really thought all you guys all you
guys just like homies it was like but
you know what it kind of worked out
really nice how professional they were
is because a lot of guys would just
probably want to hit on Jill but they
end up somehow collaborating with JK and
being our friends oh so they
should
that's awesome I didn't know that
storyline yeah I didn't either I had no
freaking idea two parts like it either
but then it would never make you
uncomfortable that like so
size like kind of chatted up with you on
set between takes I don't think Bart
gets uncomfortable
when he knows he knows I don't care
either like I'm not gonna reciprocate it
I'm not very like jealous like that
what makes you jealous is there anything
there was a big guy that was hitting on
Geo in Santa Monica and he was laughing
about it I was so pissed he wouldn't
step in to save me was it was it at a
step in point no it was like uh we were
walking he kept following me trying to
talk to me and this guy kept flying
actually walked away because we're all
walking as a group I was like please
opposite fishing yeah and then I was
like this black dude he was like started
going like this so as he was coming this
way I saw you know he speaks I started
walking that way
oh okay I don't want to have to do it
all the time she likes seeing you walk
away too that's super hot yeah she's
like I gotta chase him no I didn't like
that so would you what did you do I like
seeing independent chicks you know I
don't like seeing chicks I'm used to
abg's where it's like [__] gangs just
have straight up rumbles and shoot each
other because they started some [__] so
I like it I like feeling feminine time
to time I don't like it when the girl is
like I can't do anything about it you
know
I like seeing chicks I like seeing like
boss chicks like pow
get out of here and I'm like that's
tight I want to hid behind the bench too
what was your answer if he's in the room
right looks like you guys are like on
set
and a dude is literally asking you so
you seen anybody or what like what was
your verbal answer to that because you
can't say no right
um
and like he's with an earshot do you
have this clever way of phrasing it so
that it's like a yes but a no yeah
absolutely like that's easy how what
would you say I would say yeah oh you'd
say that you are seeing someone and then
they're like what does he look like
really is
[Laughter]
the third question is is he in this room
yeah
so at this point I know what the
intentions are and I don't even want to
take it further than that right so if he
asks a follow-up question like that I'd
be like no dude I'm really not
interested and I would just probably
leave and that's hot and I like I like
and I like observing that's the kind of
stuff and your eyes are like this Bart's
chubbed up right now you can't see yeah
he's a little I like seeing yeah he's
sitting cross-legged yeah yeah I like
seeing powerful independent chicks that
like pow here's [__] boundaries
[__] yeah yeah like I wouldn't
need to have a further conversation like
there's no more back and forth that
needs to happen at that point so I like
that and I also like death situations
too huh what's your favorite okay okay
so like you know like the the dude that
was like spitting game at yeah Santa
Monica like it he doesn't call for death
if he's just hitting on her yeah but if
he keeps going and then come on
[Music]
yeah you know
for me I'm like that's win-win I get to
see her in action pow pow but then if
someone is like yo come on then I'm like
oh it's death time
this guy's so like when I have a person
so I have a purse right and then I'll
leave it on the chair and I'm like hey
I'll be right back I'm gonna go to the
restroom can you watch it yeah and then
instead of even grabbing it and putting
it close to him he'll like leave it
where it is far away and he goes I hope
somebody takes it
and then Park goals Behind the Chair and
wait
give time
yeah that must have felt kind of funny
then because I feel like I'm sure
there's times when I may have said to
you dude your friend Bart is really cool
maybe
I think like I could feel most girls can
feel when a guy is trying to like make
moves yeah you know I never felt that
from like any of you guys
um we're gay we're honestly too gay so
because of that we were able to develop
a friendship but like other people you
can feel it like you can feel like if
what their intentions
and it's really hot outside
it's not even winter and he's going yeah
so I think at that point if I start
feeling it I'm like okay I need to start
going in a different direction yeah I
like your new Dora the Explorer hair I
think
[Laughter]
foreign